حسنًا ، حفل توقيع كبير في البيت الأبيض
اليوم حيث من المقرر أن توقع الإمارات العربية المتحدة
في
البحرين اتفاقيات تطبيع منفصلة
مع
إسرائيل ، يتم وصف الصفقات
بعبارات عملية على
أنها تعزز اقتصادات الدول الثلاث
وتقوي الأمن الإقليمي
الذي يعني بشكل أساسي تقديم
جبهة أقوى
ضد إيران مراسل CNN الدولي
سام خلي في أبو ظبي
، انضم إلينا الآن عيش حياة جيدة لرؤيتك سام ،
فما مدى أهمية
حفل التوقيع الكبير الذي سيأتي في هذا الوقت
كما هو الحال وكيف يتم عرضه
في المنطقة
حسنًا ، إنه مهم
بطرق مختلفة لأشخاص مختلفين
بشكل واضح ، حيث تشير بشكل صحيح
إلى المقدمة هناك إكليل
الجبل الدافع الرئيسي
ربما لدول الخليج
هو تأمين رابطة مع
إسرائيل يأملون في المستقبل أن تسمح
لهم بتعويض
ما يقولون هو التأثير الخبيث لإيران في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة
لدول الخليج  نظروا إلى ما حدث
في اليمن
العراق سوريا لبنان كل البلدان في درجة
عالية
من عدم الاستقرار والحرب الأهلية
والكثير من ذلك
يلومون إيران من منظور الولايات المتحدة
هناك مزايا واضحة
في أه في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية قبل
انتخابات ل
لديك حفل شبيه برجل دولة غالبًا
ما يوصف بشكل غير دقيق
بصفته اتفاق سلام بين البحرين والإمارات العربية المتحدة
بالطبع لم تكن أي من تلك
الدول في حالة حرب
سواء تم الإعلان عنها أو عدم الإعلان عنها ، ولكن
مع ذلك
كانت لحظة نجاح دبلوماسية
للإدارة الرابحة
، فلا شك في ذلك و  ثم
بالطبع بالنسبة لإسرائيل
كان لديهم صفقات سلام مناسبة مع
مصر والأردن في أعقاب النزاعات
مع هاتين الدولتين أو في هذين
البلدين في الماضي.
بالطبع في واشنطن ،
لكن الجانبين الإماراتيين والإسرائيليين قد
تقدموا بالفعل
على جبهة الأعمال فماذا يفعل  هذا
يخبرنا عن نواياهم
جيدًا في بعض الأشياء التي تفيد بأن النية
موجودة بوضوح كما تقترح
إكليل الجبل ولكن
أيضًا أن هذا كان قيد الإعداد
لفترة طويلة لم
يحدث بين عشية وضحاها في نفس الوقت
هذا  ليست اتفاقية الرخاء الأوسع
التي كان يبحث عنها جاريد كوشنر
ولكن يبدو أنها تعمل لصالح الدول العربية
وإسرائيل كما كان سام يتحدث هنا
أه لأن لديهم عدوًا مشتركًا في
إيران ، فعمان يرسل
إشارات إيجابية وعلينا أن  تذكر أن
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ذهب إلى هناك
قبل عامين ،
لذا فإن ما تم التوقيع عليه حتى الآن ثلاث
فئات إذا ألقينا نظرة هنا على
التكنولوجيا الطبية والخدمات المصرفية ، فهذه
مجالات استراتيجية حيث يمكنك رؤية
الإمارات بثروتها السيادية تستثمر
في إسرائيل
وبالتالي تحصل على نوع  من المساعدة الأمنية
التي تبحث عنها الإمارات في
البحرين ثم الدول العربية الأخرى
التي توقع على هذا هو ما يمكن
تطويره ، كما أنه يساعد إكليل الجبل في
عدم وجود تداخل  ap لا توجد
قوى متنافسة عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالاقتصاد في الوقت الحالي ، يمكن أن يكون
مكسبًا للجانبين يمتد إلى السياحة ،
فكر في المعرض في عام 2021 في نفس
الوقت وأيضًا تلك الأعمال وهذا
شيء اتبعته هنا لمدة 20
سنوات
يمكن للأعمال التجارية ترسيخ الروابط السياسية والأمنية ،
وأعتقد أن هذا هو سبب
تحركهم بسرعة كبيرة وأيضًا بوليصة تأمين
إذا لم يتم إعادة انتخاب دونالد ترامب ،
لديهم هذا التحالف
في مكانه ويريدون ترسيخه
قبل  انتخاب